i'm here with sylvia from the glamour
team and we're going to experience the
Rimmel lassen finish foundation so I'm
going to prep your skin with a lasting
finish primer just take a small amount
like a pea sized amount on the back of
your hand I actually really like a
makeup sponge for this so I find this
works really well just through the
t-zone or if you like you can take it
all the way across your skin one of my
favorite things about this foundation is
that it has comfort serum which means
it's really beautiful in a dryer skin
just make sure that it feels really
comfortable all day I like to start in
the center of the face and either tap
the brush if you want more coverage and
for areas where your skin might be a
little bit more even you can simply
smooth the brush around so now your skin
is looking really flawless I want to add
a little pop of color just to give you
that radiance back so i'm using a
lasting finish brush and i'd like to
concentrate just on the apple of the
cheek use a really large lush brush is
perfect and i love the shade if you want
to kind of go from the desk to dance so
i'm going to add a little bit more drama
to your eyes by using the color precise
eyeliner pen and you can do a nice
subtle look or you can go for something
a little bit more dramatic let's finish
with a lasting finish net so this is an
amazing red and I know that you really
like a bold lip when it comes your look
cuz I'm starting on the center of the
lips and this is your finished look